翻訳: Harue Mori
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
僕は『バスケットボールの家庭教師』っていう
事業をやってます
「チームスポーツなのに家庭教師？」って
思った人も 多いかもしれません
実際に 家庭教師的に
個人の子どもにバスケを教えに行きます
でももちろんチームに呼ばれて
行くこともあります
でもこの事業は 単に子どもたちに
バスケを教えるってだけじゃなくて
指導者を育てるっていうことも
大事なテーマなんです
子どもたちに教えるっていうことと
指導者を育てるっていうこと
この２つの活動を行っているのが
この僕の事業のポイントなんです
今日は 僕がこの事業を立ち上げる中で
学んだことを お話ししようと思います
ところで
ことわざってありますけど
ことわざに守備範囲があるって
皆さん考えたことありますかね
ことわざって万能じゃないんです
いつどんな時でも それが有効なんじゃなくて
ある限られた条件の時だけ
その教訓が有効だったりします
その代表的なことわざが
「二兎を追うものは一兎をも得ず」です
このことわざは
２つのものを手に入れようとしたら
両方手に入らない
つまり 二択に迫られたら
欲張ってどっちも取ろうとしないで
どちらか一方に集中しなさいっていう
そういう意味です
確かに 目の前にうさぎが２匹いて
左右別々の方向に逃げ出したとしたら
その瞬間に２匹を捕まえようとすると
どちらも逃してしまう
そういうことわざです
でもここで 思い出してほしいのが
先ほどのことわざの守備範囲です
このことわざの守備範囲は
今 その瞬間に
うさぎを捕まえなければならないっていう
時間的な条件です
もし 視界のずっと先に
２匹のうさぎが見えてて
これから 罠とか 餌とかを用意する
時間的な余裕があるとします
だとしたら
２匹を捕まえるつもりで準備をした人しか
２匹を捕まえることはできないんです
多くの人が
この時間的な守備範囲を考えないで
このことわざの教訓を理解してます
だから 二択に迫られた時に
どちらか一方に絞らなきゃって
どちらか一方に決めなきゃって
考えちゃうんです
AとBのこの二択
どちらにも良い点があって
諦めるには惜しい選択肢でも
二兎を追ったらどっちも手に入らない
泣く泣くどちらか一方を選んでしまう
でもそこで 考える必要があるんです
「その選択は本当に正しかったのか」っていう
それはAとBの正しい方を
選んだのかってことじゃなくて
そのAとBは本当に
二択だったのかっていうことです
二兎を追うつもりで考え尽くせば
二兎を得られるアイデアが
見つかるんじゃないでしょうか
僕たちが 普段出合っている二択の中には
実は 両方を取れる第三案が
隠れてるのではないでしょうか
僕は このことを
自分の事業立ち上げの経験から学びました
僕は小学校４年生の時に
バスケの強豪中学がある学区に転校したんです
その当時は漫画の『スラムダンク』
NBAはマイケル・ジョーダン
バスケ人気が絶頂期で
僕は日に日にバスケに夢中になっていきました
だけど早い段階で
僕はプレイヤーとしては高いレベルにいくのは
無理だなって思ってました
残念ながら 体的にも技術的にも
全国レベルの先輩たちのようになるのは
ちょっと難しいなって考えてたんです
でも 当時から僕は
人に教えるっていうことが すごく好きでした
後輩たちにバスケを教えて
その子たちが嬉しそうにしてるのを見ると
とても充実感を感じてたのを覚えてます
そんなこともあって 当時の僕は
将来中学校の先生になろうって思ってました
ただ僕は 当時からちょっと
野心家なところがあって
他の人が真似できないようなことを
達成したいっていう
そういう思いがあったんで
中学校の先生になったら
その学校を全国大会で優勝させたい
そういう指導者になりたいって
考えてたんです
これが僕が最初に考えた将来の夢 A案です
それで教員免許を取るために
僕は大学に進学します
でもそこで ある指導者との
運命的な出会いをするんです
日高哲朗先生との出会いです
日高先生のコーチングは まるで魔法でした
先生の言うとおりにシュートを打つと
なぜかシュートがよく入ったし
技術的な壁にぶつかっても
的確なアドバイスで
成長を後押ししてくださいました
その日高先生との出会いで 僕は
先生のようなコーチングを
もっと多くの子どもたちに
届けられたらいいんじゃないかなって
考えるようになったんです
そうして 僕の将来の夢は変わっていきました
最初は ひとつのチームを教えて
そのチームを強くしていくっていう一流を
イメージしてたんですけど
ひとつのチームにこだわらないで
もっと多くの子どもたちに貢献するっていう
その貢献を大きくしていくような一流も
あるんじゃないかなって
考えるようになったんです
そこで 僕は
将来 指導者になるような
学生たちを育てるために
大学の先生になろうって考えたんです
大学の先生になって 指導者を育てていって
その育てた先で
どんどん貢献を大きくしていく
そんなことを考えたわけです
これが僕の将来の夢 B案です
みなさん これ もうお分かりですかね
僕にとってこれが
無意識の二択になってたってことです
もともとは子どもに教えるのが好きで選んでた
中学校の先生になるっていう選択肢を捨てて
指導者になるっていう選択肢を選んだんです
この 子どもに教えるっていうことと
指導者になる学生たちに
指導法を教えるっていうのは
全く違う仕事です
当時の僕は
どちらか一方を選んだら
もう一方は選ぶことができないっていう
そういう発想に縛られてました
でもここから 僕の人生は急転します
大学院に進んで
勉強の家庭教師のアルバイトを
しようと思いました
そこで 依頼を受け付けるための
ホームページを作り始めたんです
作ってる途中で—
バスケットの指導者になりたいんだから
『バスケットボールの家庭教師』って
してみたら
おもしろいんじゃないかって思って
そのホームページの内容を
『バスケットボールの家庭教師』に変えて
勉強の家庭教師みたいに
家庭から依頼を受けたら
バスケを教えに行くっていう
そういう事業を始めたわけです
でも当時は 子どもたちが
バスケットボールをするといったら
どっかのチームに所属して
そのチームでしか バスケは
教わることができないっていうのは常識だった
そういう時代でした
でも 少しずつ地域によっては
指導者不足が言われ始めてたりとか
バスケ部がないっていう学校が
増えつつあったりとか
僕の事業の開始は
社会のニーズとマッチしたんだと思います
しばらくすると 依頼が増えていきました
そこで僕は—
この事業を 後輩たちにも
手伝ってもらおうと思ったんです
ただ 手伝ってもらうにしても
お金をいただいてコーチングをするわけだから
しっかりと勉強して しっかりと準備をして
指導に行くぞってことを
後輩たちに言っていきました
それで後輩たちのための
指導の勉強会も始めました
僕はそこで気付いたんです
この事業は もともとやりたかった
子どもたちに教えるっていうA案と
指導者を育てるっていうB案の
両方を取れる事業だったんです
それまで僕は
A案かB案かっていう
二択の分岐点に立たされてて
B案の夢の方にシフトしてました
でもこのAかBかっていう二択には
当時の僕には気づけなかった
気づこうともしてなかった
両方を取れるっていう第三案があったんです
僕はこの経験以来 二択に迫られたら
しかもその二択が
どちらも捨てがたい二択だったら
その両方を取れる第三案を
探すようになりました
例えば 僕の仕事の指導者っていう面では
教えるっていうことと
選手に考えさせるってことは
常に難しい二択なんです
小中学生の指導者として
きちんと教えるっていうことも
あえて教えすぎずに
選手に考えさせるってことも
どちらも大事な要素なんです
多くの場合 指導者は
このどちらかのスタイルに偏りがちになります
でも僕は この２つを同時に扱える
コーチングスタイルを目指しました
この両方を取るコーチングスタイルを
追求し続けたことによって
僕は指導者として
たくさんのチャンスを
掴んでこれたんじゃないかなって思ってます
さぁここで ちょっと思い出してみてください
これまで いくつの二択に出合ってきましたか
その二択は どちらも捨てがたいもので
でも仕方なくどちらか一方を
選んだっていう経験はないですか
例えば
学生時代だったら 部活か勉強かとか
仕事の時では 好きなことを仕事にするか
それとも安定を重視した仕事にするか
家庭を持ったら 仕事か家庭かとか
こういった僕たちに突き付けられてる
二択の中には
実は 両方を取れる第三案が
見つかるものもあるんです
今日 僕が 伝えたいアイデアっていうのは
両方とも捨てがたい二択に出合ったら
その両方を取れる第三案を
見つけようっていうことです
ただ皆さん ここで
ちょっと問題があるんです
このアイデア
例えば先ほど僕が話した
好きなことを仕事にするって
あれ 好きなことそのまま仕事にできたら
最高だなって思った人って
結構たくさんいると思うんですよ
つまり AもBも両方取れたらいいなって
思ってはいるってことです
でも ほとんどの人がそれを選ばない
やっぱり心のどっかで
二兎は追えないって考えてしまう
AもBも取れる二択を
そのAもBも取れる選択を
実際に実践するって
実践できるっていう人は本当に少ない
そう このアイデア
第三案を見つけるってアイデアの問題は
実践するのが難しいっていうところなんです
じゃあ なんで難しいんでしょうか
二択に迫られた人が
二兎を追える可能性を模索するためには
何が必要なんでしょうか
僕はポイントが３つあると思います
一つは時間の意識です
人生は 時間でできてます
AかBかっていう二択に出合ったときに
そこでの選択が
その後の人生の時間の中身を
決めてしまうんです
もしあの時 僕が 中学校の先生になるって
選択肢を選んでたら
僕は中学校の先生として時間を使ってきてるし
もし大学の先生を選んでいたら
中学校の先生を選んだ僕とは
全く違う時間の中身になるんです
人生は 時間でできてる
その人生の時間を
目一杯有意義に使い切りたい
そのためには
AかBかという二択に出合ったら
その両方をできてるC案を見つけて
それに時間を使えている人生の方が
充実してるって思うんです
この時間の意識が弱いと
第三案を見つけるってアイデアが
わかってたとしても
選びやすい二択の方に流されてしまうんです
時間は無限にはありません
限りある人生の時間を何に使うのか
その選択はとても大事な選択なんです
二つ目は想像力です
僕はC案を考えようとしたわけじゃなくて
あるアイデアを思いついて
それが後づけで
AもBも取れるC案だったって気づきました
でも 普通は逆です
AかBかっていう二択に出合ってから
想像しなければならない
まだ具体性がない第三案を見つけて
行動に移すためには
AもBも両方をやれてる自分
それに時間を使えている
その人生の時間をそれに使えている自分を
想像するっていうことが大事なんです
第三案は探そうとするんじゃなくて
想像しようとするってことが大事なんです
三つ目は強い動機です
僕は最後に「満足した！」って
人生を終えたいって ずっと思ってました
その強い動機があったからこそ
C案を思いついた時に 実際に行動に移せたし
実践し続けることができたんだと思います
人生の時間をより良いものにしたいっていう
その強い動機
それこそが
二兎を追える可能性を模索して
実践するための原動力になるんです
皆さんそれぞれの中にある
人生の時間をより良いものにしたいっていう
その動機を大事にすること
それこそがこのアイデアを実践するうえで
最も重要なことだって思うんです
さぁ これから二択に出合ったら
そしてその二択は
どちらも捨てがたい二択だったら
その両方を取れるような
あなただけの第三案を見つけてください
そして その第三案を
見つけることができたなら
ぜひそれを実践へと繋げてみてください
（拍手）